there is nothing more relevant than
freedom an entrepreneur is someone who
thinks differently I think you need to
know what your limits are or what
they're not as I said oftentimes my head
only works straight hello bleep nation
its Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in people more than they believe
in themselves and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself what I see
in you you'll be able to change the
planet to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from billionaire
entrepreneur Sam Zell and my take on his
top ten rules success rule number four
is my personal favorite and I'd love to
know which one you guys like the back
also as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the comments
below about quotes around that so other
people can be inspired by it as well and
if you leave it within the first couple
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of two daily prizes
I've been getting on challenges I've
been trying to find out how good I could
be how well I could do it and in the end
has the real benefit of being a
successful entrepreneur is freedom there
is nothing more relevant than freedom
being able to get up every day and
respond to what's out there to accept
the challenges to constantly find out
how good you are and with it comes a lot
of freedom an entrepreneur is someone
who thinks differently someone who
recognizes and understands opportunity
but combines that recognition of
opportunity with solutions and then in
the end it's all about curiosity
I've never met an entrepreneur who was
successful
who wasn't extraordinarily curious from
my perspective I start every potential
investment focused on what's the
downside and frankly from my opinion my
perspective if we do a deal and we
identify the downside and we're correct
then I view that as a successful
endeavor even if the transaction didn't
work I think you need to know what your
limits are or what they're not I answer
people that my whole life has always
been about testing my limits so you
almost say that the one thing is knowing
what your limits are not so that you can
push yourself Wow
other way to put it is the definition of
someone who's reached his goals is he's
a schmuck I just spent my whole life
trying to make sure that I never reach
my goals I would and I keep adjusting
the bar to make sure that I can never
say I'm there none of this could
possibly happen with our Ariel Waichman
and without his basic abhorrence of
conventional wisdom in many respects he
and you both share an extraordinary
common concept and that is neither one
of you knew what you couldn't do and by
virtue of not knowing what you can't do
you just try and do it and that's what
entrepreneurship is all about first of
all I think optimism is a condition I
think you I think being optimistic is
just a wonderful gift that unfortunately
not everybody has and and if you are
optimistic and you can see the silver
lining rather than the black cloud I
think it gives you self confidence and
makes you a more effective player I
think that more than anything else I
have been willing to tackle almost
anything that came down the pike ah when
you think about all the businesses
within all the different disciplines
that we are confronted with there were a
hundred times or I could say you know
not me but the answer is that as opposed
to trying to be a maven on different
companies or different strategies
I think the key has always been to
simplify everything and never forget
that the shortest distance between two
points is a straight line and your job
is to help people see that spring
exactly and you know you work for me for
a while and you know that I spend my
entire day listening to my people
pitch me ideas and it all starts with if
you can't tell me what you want in two
sentences then my attention span is over
and so I've got to make people just
still their ideas and simplify them to a
point where the delivery of the idea
itself is the essence of simplicity so
big in schools and I think they're
beginning to change but particularly in
the eighties the business schools
focused on if you could just turn the
page there's the formula that tells you
how to do it and the answer is there are
no formulas and and success and failure
are our combination of judgment and
external events but it starts and ends
with a simple idea and your gut but your
gut has played a very key role though in
your business in your in your success I
think that I have been willing to have
an opinion and then execute accordingly
I'm a voracious reader I mean the idea
that I'm sitting up here without
something to read is kind of against my
nature and somehow or other and I can't
explain it
I've developed the ability to read and
quote seek out anomalies if you read as
much as I do things start to follow
patterns and then something peculiar
happens and something gets entered into
the equation that doesn't fit and I was
I gave the example about the fact that
I've been reading all the stuff
and I had numerous repetitious
references to Williston South Dakota and
I looked it up in Lewiston was 20,000
people and I just couldn't figure out
why I kept coming up
in my reading and obviously the Bakken
Shale and all this stuff but still I
basically got out of a plane and went to
see it and and from that that result
you know emanated a lot of other things
but that's just kind of typical you know
I went to Indian two or three because
outsourcing kept coming up in my reading
and I didn't know any I didn't
understand it so I had to go see it
I think philosophically I've always been
someone who has to go see it I think
that you know part of the definition of
an entrepreneur is is an extraordinary
observer
I've never met an entrepreneur who
wasn't a very good observer because it's
those observations that all come
together and lead to conclusions and so
I try my best to be as knowledgeable as
possible and yet try and do the best I
can to not clog my capabilities with
information that useless isn't the right
word but maybe conventional and doesn't
really give me a prospectus Tribune LBO
which you helped lead was effectively
they argue fraudulent because Tribune
Company was already already insolvent
when you took it over how you going to
settle that you negotiated with it well
I think the answer is that you know many
of the bankruptcy cases have fraudulent
conveyance arguments made most of the
junior creditors in most of the
scenarios will allege a fraudulent
conveyance in the end it's very
difficult to prove number one number two
in this particular case I don't think
it's valid
but ultimately it becomes a basis for
negotiation is it an option on the table
for you to to give up your warrants to
by 40%
attribution for five hundred million in
the negotiation that an option that
you're willing to consider I don't think
that that structure and that original
plan will survive the bankruptcy can we
ask you if you regret this decision I
mean is this the worst business decision
you ever made yeah I mean I mean it's
certainly the most amount of money I've
ever lost in a single deal but we had a
turn back time yeah but you know if you
could I know as you know it's like maybe
I should have married somebody else
yeah your wife is listening no but she
is I'm sure but the answer you know the
answer is that you can't look back as
I've said often times my head only works
straight so the answer is if we made a
mistake and or didn't work out so it
didn't worked out what happened in the
past
a in the past my head only looks for
doesn't turn out washes the history of
the LA Times in a lot of different
places
- really sorry about that
but there isn't anything that you knew
all afternoon is addressed the future
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Silverman to ask
me to if there's someone you like better
profile in their future top ten please
check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick charter to Roberto
Latini thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and
taking that awesome picture and post in
it it's amazing it too that you found
your one word outstanding as well and I
hope you're applying it to your life and
your business to get outstanding results
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
Angela Street
my junior and senior year in college I
got a job as a traveling salesman for
Alan Curtis industries we sky sold suave
and spraynet Endon shampoo and because I
was a summer employee I got the worst
account and I spent the entire summer
having people just beat the [ __ ] out of
my ID walked in I'd say hi I'm family
Curtis and these people would just
ignore me or send me down in the
basement and basically said no all day
long and what I learned from that was
that I finally invented an answer when I
said I am from Alan Curtis and they said
so and I said so it gives me up the
street and that and you know there is no
greater lesson to be learned than
rejection and I doubt that anybody can
be a successful entrepreneur if they
haven't dealt with rejection and the
more you deal with it the better you get
those guys out of Wrigley Field who gets
paid paid 35 million dollars a year to
get it
one out of three times so I only try to
be right 60 or 70 percent of the time
the real challenge is when you're wrong
that you've calibrated the risk so that
you can survive to play the next act I
always view myself differently I March
to a different tune
I had just installed ah--this they have
you know just enormous self-confidence
maybe not justified but sometimes it
doesn't matter because if you believe
that's all that comes but that's always
been you know part of my characteristics
and I teach entrepreneurship I talk
about you know how true entrepreneurs
ultimately have this innate
self-confidence I mean they never fail
sometimes it doesn't work out but they
never fail and they you know they can
get up off the floor whether it's Sam
Walton or Fred Smith and you know FedEx
or any others they have adjusted
unequivocal beliefs in their ability to
solve problems